c'est difficile d'avoir des parents qui
se bat pour la liberté pour des valeurs
des idées ils m'ont appelée elsa pour
les yeux d'elsa le poème d'aragon et
angela pour angela davis la militante
black panthers qui était en prison
l'année de ma naissance
contrairement à ceux qui m'ont prénommé
comme ça moi je n'ai rien d'une héroïne
mes parents m'ont élevée en dehors des
cases
je me suis toujours senti à côté j'ai
toujours cherché ma place mon père était
un grand dessinateur de presse
il gagnait bien sa vie et en homme de
gauche il était contre la propriété
alors ils dépensaient tout mais ils nous
offraient vie magnifique
il nous a rendus très très heureuse
chaque année on allait à la fête de
l'huma alors on n'y allait pas un rer ou
en car on y allait en jaguar et puis moi
j'avais des robes
une robe à smocks de chez bonpoint avec
un noeud dans les cheveux ressembler à
un oeuf de pâques c'était complètement
ridicule mais j'étais heureuse la main
dans la main de mon père dans ses allées
qui sentait la merguez
j'ai trouvé que les femmes était belle
les hommes étaient costauds et chaque
année donc on allait à la fête de l'huma
parce que mon père dédicacer des livres
et puis on était assis tous les deux à
côté et je regardais ces gens qui
venaient avec leur amour leur
casse-croûte leur famille faire la queue
pour un dessin pour une dédicace et un
jour j'en ai eu assez d'être de l'autre
côté de la table j'ai eu envie de faire
le tour pour changer mon regard pour ne
plus être là pour être avec les autres
et c'était magique
et c'était bien ça a changé mon regard
sur la vie et sur la société
on habitait dans le 6e j'allais à
l'école alsacienne et ont invité pas
tout le temps au boom alors je n'étais
pas malheureux rien mais on a invité pas
tout le temps au bout parce que mon père
dessiner des mamans nu et qu' il était
communiste disait qu'il était communiste
donc encore une fois j'étais pas
vraiment à ma place j'étais toujours à
côté
en fait jusqu'à maintenant en tout cas
mon parcours n'avait rien ni de
militants ni d'héroïque pourtant
pourtant
pourtant 7 janvier 2015
à 11 heures je suis en train d'écrire un
article et je suis là j'arrive pas à
trouver mes mots je n'arrive pas à
écrire l'article alors je fais quelque
chose que je fais rarement je regarde
les informations sur internet
et puis c'est là en même temps que tout
le monde que je découvre qu'il ya une
fusillade à charlie hebdo j'ai peur j'ai
peur j'ai
j'ai le plexus qui se bloquent
je me sens devenir toute blanche alors
j'appelle mon père dit x 20 x 30 x il
répond pas alors j'appelle ma mère dix
fois vingt fois et elle répond pas alors
j'appelle le père de mes filles à
revault qui est sur place et je lui dis
que je veux venir avec lui sur place il
me dit pas bougé il me dit qu'il va me
rappeler et qui va me raconter ce qui se
passe
il me rappelle il me rappelle et une
digue charb est mort alors lâche jeu je
comprends que c'est grave
je comprends qu'il se passe quelque
chose de grave
et tout d'un coup j'ai une pensée très
étrange un peu dur mais je me dis que je
veux pas que que mon père est mal je
veux pas que mon père ait peur alors je
préfère qu'il soit mort mais je veux pas
qu'il soit blessé
arnaud me rappelle
et il me dit que c'est fini mais moi je
comprends pas ce qui est fini qu'est-ce
qui est finie et il dit que il me dit
qu'il est mort que mon père est mort ce
jour-là il n'y a pas que mon père qui
est décédé cinq dessinateurs de charlie
hebdo ont été massacrés tignes où ce
jardin cabu honoré d'ailleurs sa fille
dans la salle aujourd'hui et mon père
georges wolinski
ce ne sont pas les seules douze
personnes en tout est ton ou été pardon
tu es l'homme de ménage c'était son
premier jour le policier puis les gens
de la rédaction tous tous massacrés avec
une balle de kalachnikov je les cieux
après mais une balle de kalachnikov ça
ça explose un corps alors devant cette
explosion sur aussi les réseaux sociaux
sur internet sur instagram sur mon
téléphone je suis rentré pour aller
m'occuper de ma maman et en arrivant
chez eux
j'ai regardé le bureau de mon père je
saurai parce que c'est toujours un
souvenir assez jolie pour moi ce moment
quand même même dans la douleur et dans
la tristesse
il y avait ses dessins ses planches à
dessin ses livres et c'est à ce moment
là que j'ai compris
que papa était partie mais pas wolinski
qu'on pouvait tuer des hommes mais nous
on ne pouvait pas tuer des idées
je n'aurais jamais imaginé cette
manifestation du 11 janvier
ce jour là toute la france s'est levé
pour ces hommes et ces femmes qui ont
été tuées entre le 7 et le 9
en même temps c'est c'est pas facile de
faire son deuil
quand on est 4 millions mais c'est
extraordinaire de voir de cons ce tous
ensemble qu'on se soulève
je vais vous dire j'ai même cru qu'on
allait tous gagnés je vais vous faire
une confidence j'ai même cru à la
révolution
un jour on s'est soulevé on s'est
indigné un jour ça fait moins d'un an
qui sont morts et qu'est-ce qui a changé
depuis
on est tous rentrer chez soi et on a
fait comme si de rien n'était alors moi
aussi j'ai fait ça hein faut surtout pas
culpabiliser ni sans vouloir suis pas là
pour faire la morale et tout parce que
moi j'ai fait pareil
moi aussi j'ai fait comme si de rien
n'était parce que c'est très dur de
vouloir exterminer un état d'esprit
c'est très dur d'aller à l'affrontement
et au combat mais je me pose je vous
pose une question aujourd'hui c'est
qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant
qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant moi je
ne me sens pas je ne me sens pas assez
forte à ces philosophes à ses politiques
pour y répondre seul en revanche je suis
sûr d'une chose c'est si on est divisé
on va pas y arriver si on vit avec la
peur la plus immonde des peurs qui est
la peur de l'autre
on va pas s'en sortir alors c'est vrai
on est pas tous dans un film on s'aime
pas tous mais si on n'est pas ensemble
est bon on va se faire chier
mon père mon père lui aussi il était
pour le mélange
il était assez malheureux ces dernières
années et comprenait pas notre société
les politiques les guerres de religion
lui non plus il n'avait pas la solution
s'il était là aujourd'hui je crois qu
d'abord en bon papa il me dirait de
faire attention à mes gros mots parce
que j'en dis tout le temps et ensuite je
crois qu'il aimerait pas qu'on soit
séparé par une scène ils préféreraient
sûrement qu'on partage un grand plat
genre un grand couscous puissent
ensemble puisque c'était son plat
préféré
et surtout il voudrait effectivement
qu'on soit uni tous différents mais unie
pas divisée
alors c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'on peut
plus faire semblant qu'aujourd'hui on
peut rire de tout et avec tout le monde
mais on n'a pas le droit de ne pas être
ensemble
on n'a pas le droit de ne plus être unis
pour vous pour nous pour nos enfants
pour demain ils ne peuvent pas je vous
le demande
ils ne peuvent pas être mort pour rien
merci
[Applaudissements]